We will always come out on top o
These lies at the core of of our
but also your tradition
However,
the horizon
never stays clear for a while.
Once the old evil is defeated,
then Yuan is attempting
to rise its head.
Do you have a feeling
that the evil will crumble once
I can see
in your eyes now
we seeing the same way as you do
We know freedom will win
We know.
We know Russia will lose
and we we really know the weak.
The weak theory will change the
And this will be a change
that the world has long needed.
The United Kingdom
is marching with us towards the
I think
the most important victory
of our lifetime, it will be a vi
over the very idea of the war.
After we win together, any aggre
it doesn't matter.
Big or small will know what awai
If he attacks international orde
Any aggressor
any aggressor who will try to pu
the boundaries by force, who wil
destruction and death on other p
who will try to endure his dicta
and then at the expense of other
blood in criminal and unprovoked
At the Kremlin, does
any aggressor is going to lose?
The visit comes as the UK
announces a new round of sanctio
against Russia.
It is also stepping up
its training of Ukrainian troops
in an international diplomatic e
Nic Robertson is live in London
just outside parliament
Nic, this is quite a trip,
a significant appearance
for one of the closest relations
in this war between Ukraine and
The UK what is the actual functi
Is he looking for more help?
Lots of talk about a Russian
a new Russian offensive against
I think
part of it is not just about new
He wants fighter jets
and he's got part of that,
if you will, that the British
are announcing today
they're expanding their training
They're training
Ukrainian troops on the challeng
to tanks,
of course, the UK,
the first to commit tanks to Ukr
They're now going to train
Ukrainian fighter pilots on to u
NATO's standard aircraft for the
No commitment on the aircraft.
So that's something that steps
in the direction of what
President Lansky wants.
But I think also he's
trying to,
if you will, futureproof the sup
So thanks for the support
that he's had in the past and fu
Proof it by coming here
and thanking people personally,
thanking politicians
on both sides of the aisle.
It's been exceptional from the g
I have to say.
The prime minister
driving an hour outside of Londo
to meet President Zelensky
of his military aircraft when he
but then spending that hour
talking as they drove in.
I was outside Ten Downing Street
when President Zelensky walked i
I stood outside the
when a lot of leaders, U.S.
presidents as well,
have walked in the building.
There was a thunderous applause
from all those inside
Downing Street as he walked
in, thunderous applause
when he spoke to all them
of parliamentarians here today.
And I think he kind of hit this
the tone of the speech.
As always, with presidency, Lyns
fine tuned to the audience,
but there were a couple of momen
that stood out evoking Winston
Churchill, thanking Boris Johnso
the former prime minister
there in the audience.
But he said
in the U.K.,
your king is an Air Force pilot
in the Ukraine, our Air Force pi
all the king,
he said, because there are so fe
and they do such a heroic job.
And then he gave an Air Force
fighter pilots
helmet to the parliamentary spea
And emblazoned on it were the wo
we have the freedom?
Give us the wings to protect it.
Very powerful speech,
very emotional,
reaching to the core of
sort of British identity,
but obviously getting at that po
And to your point, Jim, what did
He wants fighter planes.
Did he lay on the message stick?
Yes, he did.
Did he get the applause? 100%